programming throwdown episode 58 scaling websites take it away jason hey everyone we are doing an interview show and we're super excited to have Daniel Moore on the show and he is an expert at scaling websites, he works at Fog Creek Software So Daniel, why don't you tell the audience a little bit about yourself Yeah, I'm a software developer, I've been developing software for, I guess, about 10 years now, always messing around on computers. And my recent project, HyperDev, is something we started at Fog Creek to really make development easier for most people, like broader than just developers. And we're hoping that it will be a tremendous success requiring more than one database. All right.
Programming Throwdown 第58期：网站扩展，Jason，请开始吧。嘿，大家好，我们正在进行一期访谈节目，非常高兴能邀请到 Daniel Moore 来到节目中，他是网站扩展方面的专家，在 Fog Creek Software 工作。那么 Daniel，不如向听众简单介绍一下你自己吧。好的，我是一名软件开发人员，我想我已经开发软件大约 10 年了，一直都在捣鼓电脑。我最近的项目 HyperDev 是我们在 Fog Creek 启动的一个项目，旨在让大多数人（不仅仅是开发人员）都能更轻松地进行开发。我们希望它能取得巨大成功，并且需要用到不止一个数据库。好的。
That's awesome. So, cool. So, a lot of people, you know, we have a lot of people on this show who are taking CS 101 or maybe Electrical Engineering 101 and they're working on Arduinos and things like that.
太棒了。那么，酷。我们节目中有很多听众正在学习计算机科学导论或电气工程导论，他们正在使用 Arduino 之类的东西。
I've never built a website. I took, I actually hadn't built a website in a really long, until much later in my career when I got into the sort of web. And so for someone who's never done web, you know, what is, you know, you hear about the web stack, right? You know, like, what is that?
我从来没建过网站。实际上，直到我职业生涯的后期接触到网络相关领域时，我才真正开始建网站。所以对于一个从未接触过网络的人来说，你经常会听到“Web 栈”这个词，对吧？那到底是什么意思呢？
What are some examples? And what does that really mean? Yeah, I guess these days it's kind of weird actually because it used to be i guess like five or ten years ago you'd say like the lamp stack which basically would be linux apache my sql and php so you'd have these like discrete components like an operating system layer, a web server like Apache, a programming language like PHP even have a web server under your control, much less like a database. You could use all kinds of different things. So it's actually getting pretty weird today where it used to be like, you could say,
有哪些例子？这到底意味着什么？是的，我想现在的情况其实有点奇怪，因为在五到十年前，你会说 LAMP 栈，也就是 Linux、Apache、MySQL 和 PHP。你会拥有这些离散的组件，比如操作系统层、像 Apache 这样的 Web 服务器、像 PHP 这样的编程语言，甚至不需要完全控制 Web 服务器，更不用说数据库了。你可以使用各种不同的东西。所以今天的情况确实变得很奇怪，过去你可以说，
this is the stack. Now there's so many different choices and so many different ways you can combine things that even drawing the line between like web versus mobile or APIs versus sort of just purely client applications, it gets a little blurrier. So, so you mentioned the like LAMP stack, the Linux, Apache, MySQL, PHP stack. I mean, is that, do people still use that or is that i mean that was super popular you know
这就是 Web 栈。现在有太多不同的选择和组合方式，以至于在 Web 与移动端，或者 API 与纯客户端应用程序之间划清界限变得有些模糊了。所以，你提到了 LAMP 栈，即 Linux、Apache、MySQL、PHP 栈。我的意思是，人们还在使用它吗？或者说，它在很久以前非常流行，现在是不是正在逐渐淡出，还是有其他东西正在取代它，又或者它仍然占据着主要份额？我的意思是，确实有很多更新的东西，但我认为就像几十年前的 Java 和 COBOL 一样，它们依然存在且应用广泛。如果它们曾经很流行，通常不会直接消失。它们只是被更时髦或更新的东西所掩盖了。
a while ago is that kind of fading out and are other things kind of taking it or is that is that still have the lion's share uh i mean it's definitely there are a lot of newer things but i think there's still much like there's still a ton of java and still a ton of cobalt from decades ago. Like the things don't just disappear if they were popular. They usually even gain popularity. It's just they get eclipsed by bigger things that are either trendier or newer.
是的，这很有道理。这很有道理。我现在个人最喜欢的 Web 栈是纯 JavaScript Web 栈。我在之前的节目中说过，我最喜欢它的一点是你可以复用验证代码。所以，如果你的客户端代码规定名字只能是三个字母，而有人黑进浏览器输入了一个两个字母的名字，在服务器端你也可以使用完全相同的代码
Yeah, that makes sense. That makes sense. My personal favorite web stack now is the like pure JavaScript web stack. And I've said this on past episodes that the thing I like the most about it is the fact that you can duplicate your validation code. So if you have some code on the client that says this person's name can only be three letters and someone sort of hacks their browser and gets a two-letter name in, on the client that says this person's name can only be three letters and someone sort of hacks their browser and gets a two-letter name in on the server side you can have the same exact code
来拦截它，这样你就不用重复编写所有的健全性检查了。所以这是我最喜欢的。你现在最喜欢哪种 Web 栈？让我看看，我实际上一直在尝试使用纯客户端应用程序。就像纯静态的 HTML 和 JavaScript。但我不是手动构建并将它们放在服务器上，而是将它们构建在 GitHub Pages 仓库中，第一个应用程序允许你加载任何 GitHub 仓库，然后进行编辑并发布到其 GitHub Pages 上。所以它就像一个独立的基于浏览器的编辑器。而且它是纯客户端的。所以没有操作系统，没有数据库。
to block it and you don't have to you know kind of duplicate all of those sanity checks so that's that's my favorite what's what's your favorite kind of web stack that's out there right now let's see, I've actually been experimenting with some stuff using pure client-side applications. It's like just static HTML and JavaScript. But instead of building them by hand and putting them up on a server, I'd build it on a GitHub Pages repository, where the first application lets you load any GitHub repository and then edit it and publish it to its GitHub pages. So it's kind of like a self-contained browser-based editor. And it's purely client-side. So there's no OS, no database.
这只是一个奇怪的实验，我想，这实际上引导我做了很多最近一直在做的事情。是的，我想你刚才把我的大脑搞糊涂了。我的意思是，如果你没有服务器，那你怎么存储用户数据和所有这些东西呢？是的，对于这类应用程序，我还没怎么处理用户数据。
And it's just kind of a weird experiment, I guess, that actually led me into a lot of the stuff I've been doing recently. Yeah, I think you just melted my brain. I mean, if you don't have a server, then how do you store the user data and all of that stuff? Yeah, so on these type of applications, I haven't done much of the user data stuff.
你可以使用 Amazon DynamoDB，实际上你可以用它做一些非常疯狂的事情。很多 Amazon 的东西都很奇怪，因为它功能非常强大，但很难上手。我甚至会说，想象一下走进一艘巨大的外星飞船，一切都让人摸不着头脑，
You can do stuff with Amazon DynamoDB, and you can actually do some really crazy stuff with that. A lot of the Amazon stuff is weird because it's really powerful, but it's hard to get into. It's actually like, I would say, imagine going into a giant alien spaceship and nothing makes sense,
但它们的功能确实非常强大。它不是为人类设计的，但你可以破译这些神秘的符号，然后弄清楚一些东西，并将这种强大的技术带给其他人。这就是 Amazon 的东西。所以你可以使用像 DynamoDB 和所有这些 Cognito 身份提供程序之类的东西。
but it's all very powerful stuff. It was not designed for humans, but you can like decipher these cryptic glyphs and then figure something out and bring this powerful technology to others. And that's Amazon stuff. And so you can use stuff like DynamoDB and all these cognito identity provider things.
你甚至可以使用 Amazon 服务作为数据库后端的等价物，使用 GitHub Pages 或 S3 作为托管 Web 服务器（如 Apache 或 Nginx）的等价物，来构建一个纯客户端 Web 应用。
And you can even do like a pure client side web app using Amazon services as the equivalent to a database backend using GitHub pages or S3 as the equivalent of like hosting a web server like Apache or
思考这些东西真的很奇怪，因为不清楚我们是否还需要 Web 服务器。有人需要提供网页，肯定某个地方有服务器，但你还需要管理自己的 Web 服务器吗？答案通常是不需要。哦，我明白了。所以你的意思是，为了给那些从未建过网站的人解释一下，通常你有一个服务器，服务器上运行着数据库，还有一些服务器端代码。发生的情况是，你提供一些网页，客户端回来请求说：“给我这张图片。”你给它。请求说：“给我这段文字。”你给它。但如果它说：“给我关于我自己的信息，比如人口统计数据之类的。”你会说，
Nginx. And it's like really weird to kind of think about this stuff because it's not clear as like do we need web servers? It's like well someone to kind of think about this stuff because it's not clear it's like do we need web servers it's like well someone needs to serve the web page there's definitely a server somewhere but do you need to manage your own web server anymore and the answer is not often oh i see so what you're saying is you so just to explain it for people who have never built a website, usually you have a server and the server has a database running and it also has some server side code. And what happens is, you know, you serve sort of some web pages and the client comes back and says, you know, give me this picture. You give it to them. Give me this, you know, paragraph, you give it to them. But then it says, you know, give me this information about, you know, myself, like some demographics or something. And you say,
哦，那不是网站的一部分，是在数据库里的。所以服务器会调用数据库，获取用户请求的信息，然后发回给客户端。Dan，你的意思是，为什么不跳过中间人，直接让客户端连接到数据库获取信息呢？我想这是真的。我从来没想过。我的意思是，也许人们会滥用它，但你可以对某些客户端进行速率限制之类的。
oh, that's not part of the website that's on the database. And so the server will make a call to the database, you know, get the person's information that they're asking for, and then send it back to the client. And Dan, what you're saying is, well, why don't you just skip the middleman and just have the client connect directly to the database and get information? I guess it's true. I never really thought about it. I mean, I guess maybe people could abuse that, but you could just rate limit certain clients and things like this you can
你可以让客户端在与服务器通信时获得凭证，从而限定它们在数据库资源上的交互权限。以 Amazon 为例，你可以获得一个 S3 上传策略，并给用户一个限定在存储桶子文件夹中的上传策略，然后他们可以直接上传到那里。如果他们试图上传到该范围之外，Amazon 会检查他们的凭证并说：“哦，他们没有权限”，然后拦截它。
have like the client can when they talk to your server they basically get credentials that scope their permissions of what they can interact with on the database resource so you can get like using amazon again as an example you could get an s3 upload policy and give a user an upload policy that's scoped like a subfolder in a bucket, and then they can upload directly to that. And if they try to upload outside of that, Amazon checks their credentials and says, oh, they aren't allowed, so they block it.
所以，与其说“我要直接上传一千兆字节到服务器，然后服务器再上传到 Amazon，然后我们再回头告诉用户‘好的，一小时后完成了’”，用户可以直接上传，只需传递这些非常小且容易处理的凭证。酷，太棒了。是的，这真的很酷。我从来没想过，但听起来……我第一次听到你提到时，我以为你在说 Meteor.js，
So then instead of saying, I'm going to upload one gigabyte straight to the server, and then the server's going to upload it to Amazon, and then we're going to go back and tell the user, okay, it finished like an hour later then the server is going to upload it to amazon and then we're going to go back and tell the user okay it finished like an hour later the user can upload it directly and uh just by passing in these uh credentials around which are very small and much easier cool that's amazing yeah it's really cool i never really thought about it but yeah it sounds i i first one of you had mentioned i thought you were talking about Meteor.js
你在网络上传输大量数据并构建那种客户端数据库。这本身很酷，但你描述的实际上更好，因为你甚至不需要服务器了。是的，这绝对是一种进化，因为 Meteor 出现得有点早，在人们清楚地意识到可以这样做之前。
where you're passing a bunch of data over the wire and building that sort of client-side database. That's cool in its own right, but actually what you're describing is even better because you don't have to even have the server then. Yeah, it's like definitely sort of an evolution because Meteor came out a little early, before it was so clear that you could do this type of thing.
他们可能是先驱之一，特别是在整个栈中使用 JavaScript 的趋势，以及客户端验证和服务器端验证，模糊了界限，让你不必非得区分服务器端代码和客户端代码。我认为这很有趣，但我实际上觉得你必须知道数据最终存储在哪里。因为如果它在与你的 Web 服务器同一台机器的数据库中，
They're probably one of the pioneers, especially in the JavaScript across the whole stack trend and the client-side validation and server-side validation and sort of blurring it so you don't have to see the distinction necessarily between your server side code versus your client side code. I think that's interesting, but I actually feel you kind of have to know the distinction of where your data ends up. Because if it's in the database on the same machine as
那会有特定的性能特征和影响。如果它在 S3 存储桶中，并且 Amazon 将其托管在某个区域，那会有不同的影响。所以如果你不知道数据最终在哪里，你可能会做出错误的决定。但这通常不算太糟。即使使用 Meteor 和 Amazon，大多数人也不知道。即使是专业的软件工程师，也不知道数据最终去了哪里，或者他们在做什么，但我们还是设法应付过来了。
your web server, that has certain performance characteristics and implications. And if it's in an S3 bucket and Amazon hosts it in a region, that has different implications. So if you don't know where your data actually ends up, you might make some bad decisions. But it's usually not too bad. Even with Meteor and Amazon, most people don't know. Even professional software engineers don't know even professional software engineers don't really know where their data ends up or what they're doing but we get by somehow
明白了。所以我一直在读的那个新栈，显然已经流行了一段时间，但我对 Web 开发不太感兴趣，最近出于某种原因引起了我的注意，那就是无服务器架构（Serverless）。对于你的问题，Jason，这有点奇怪，因为仍然有服务器，但这是你在托管服务提供商上运行 Lambda 函数的地方。所以不存在监听传入套接字或请求的机器的概念。
gotcha so the the new stack i've been reading out which apparently has been uh popular for a little while but i'm not that into web development and i just started recently for some reason catching my eye is the serverless architecture, which to your question, Jason, is kind of weird because there's still a server, but this is where you run lambdas on a hosting provider. So there isn't this notion of a machine listening for sockets that come in
相反，它在监听一堆网站、一堆客户端。当请求进来时，它会启动一个带有少量代码的进程，就像一个函数（Lambda），执行该 Lambda，然后消失。所以你不需要在服务器上持续关注。这些东西只是弹出来，你只需要把它们放在托管服务提供商那里。你不在特定的机器上。你们俩以前见过吗？
or requests that come in for some information. Instead, it's listening for a bunch of websites, a bunch of clients. And when a request comes in, it spins up a process with a bit of code, almost like a function, a lambda, executes that lambda, and then goes away. So you don't have an ongoing concern on a server. And these just kind of pop up, and you just have them on a hosting provider. You're not on a specific machine. Have either of you guys seen that before?
我想，App Engine 就是那样的，对吧？或者不是？我想所有的提供商可能都有某种等价物。我知道 AWS 有一个，他们命名为 Lambda，甚至像
I think that's, isn't that the App Engine is like that, right, or no? I think they, all the providers probably have some sort of equivalent. I know AWS has one, they named Lambda, and even like
还有其他的，比如 Google Container Engine 有一些容器化的东西，虽然有点不同，但它们扮演的角色类似，即不是说有一台服务器，你把整个应用放在上面，而是把一切都分解成更小的部分。你只把一个函数放在一个小服务上，
there's other ones like Google Container Engine has something container focused which is a little different but they're kind of filling similar roles in that instead of saying there's one server and you put your whole app on it, everything is kind of broken down into smaller pieces. You just put one function on one little service
然后这就是你可以处理的单元，它有不同的权衡。把事情变得非常小，会让一些事情变得更好，但也会让一些事情变得更糟。是的，没错。这很有道理。那么前端工程师是否必须关心后端呢？为什么不能有人只在客户端用 JavaScript 做所有事情？我想现在你可以了，除非你仍然必须……你得与某个服务对话，即使是使用 jQuery AJAX 请求之类的，你仍然必须说，
and then that's the unit you can deal with which has different trade-offs. They're making things really small, make some things better, but some things worse. Yeah, right. That makes sense. So do front-end engineers have to, you know, why do they sort of have to care about the back-end? Like, why can't someone just do everything in JavaScript on the client? I guess these days you can, except you still have to... You talk to some service, even if it's using a jQuery AJAX request or something, you still have to say,
“好的，如果我希望客户端在多个设备上拥有数据，或者与另一个人交谈，或者在未来的某个时间点与此交互，我需要获取这些数据并将其放在互联网上的某个地方。”它不一定非得在我的服务器上，但它需要是某种存储提供商，某种数据库等价物，某种我可以存储信息然后稍后取回的东西。所以你至少需要知道如何进行那些 jQuery AJAX 调用，说：“好的，把这张图片放在某个地方，稍后我们可以取回它。”
okay, if I want the client to have data on more than one device or to talk to another person or to interact with this at some point in the future i need to take this data and put it somewhere on the internet it doesn't necessarily need to be on my server but it needs to be some kind of storage provider some kind of database equivalent some kind of uh thing where i can store information and then get it back later and so you at least need to know like how to make those jQuery AJAX calls to say, okay, put this image somewhere and then later we can get it back.
或者甚至把这个用户的登录信息放在某个地方，稍后当他们回来时，我们可以验证是同一个人并给他们同一个账户。那么如果你必须做一些计算呢？比如说我正在制作一个专门放 Patrick 表情包的网站。所以我必须做一些计算，我实际上必须获取某人写的文字，并把它画在 Patrick 的图片上，比如他穿着西装之类的。
Or even put this user's login info somewhere and then later when they come back, we can verify it's the same person and give them their same account. So what if you have to do like, let's say I'm making a site just for Patrick memes. And so, you know, I have to do some computation. I actually have to take the text someone writes and I have to draw it, you know, on an image of Patrick, like, you know, wearing a suit or, you know, whatever.
如果你必须做某种计算密集型的事情，这怎么融入整个框架呢？我的意思是，我想你会让其他服务器与同一个数据库对话，进行数字运算之类的。是的，如果像在图片上添加文字，你实际上可以在浏览器中使用 HTML5、Canvas API 等在客户端完成所有这些操作。所以有些事情是相当简单的，
Like you have to do some kind of computationally intensive thing how would you how does that sort of fit into this whole framework i mean i guess i guess you would like you would have other servers that talk to the same database that do number crunching or something yeah like if it's something like adding text on an image you could actually do that all client-side in the browser using HTML5, using the Canvas API, and things like that. And so there are some things that are fairly simple
你可以分发给所有客户端，说：“好的，你可以在本地进行此计算，然后只需上传完成的图片。”在移动端，这有点难，因为资源受限。所以你必须对你的受众以及需要在服务器上执行的任务限制有所了解。
that you then can distribute to all the clients and say, okay, you can do this computation locally and then just upload the finished image. On mobile, it's a little harder because they're more resource constrained. So you have to have some idea of your audience and what's the limit of the task that you need to do on a server.
但如果你必须做一个巨大的……假设你正在制作一个爬取整个互联网并编译这些巨大数据库的搜索引擎，你不能指望在别人的客户端设备上完成所有这些。有些计算是你希望在内部完成的，尽管想象一下如果你制作一个搜索引擎，每个客户端只更新数据库的一小部分会是什么样子，这很有趣。我不知道，这很奇怪也很酷，我喜欢它。是的，我的意思是，如果 google.com 运行一点点 SETI 程序，我们现在就在和外星人交谈了。我们早就找到他们了。这很有趣。所以如果你去搜索什么东西，你必须在得到结果之前贡献一部分工作。是的，我想人们正在研究类似的事情，
But if you have to do a giant... Say you're making a search engine that crawls all of the internet and compiles these giant databases, you can't necessarily expect to do all of that on someone's client device there are some computations that are uh you would kind of like to have internally although it would be interesting to imagine what would it be if you made a search engine where each client just updated a little
我想，类似于比特币和所有这些奇怪的区块链东西以及分布式信任。我不知道，我想我们也才刚刚开始。我们将看看它是否最终能在大规模上用于分布式搜索引擎之类的事情。我认为从数学上讲这似乎是可能的，但我想我们将看看它是如何实现的。那会很酷，就像你获得某个服务的访问权限，但前提是你让你的电脑计算一会儿数字。这其中有一些很酷的东西，特别是如果它是某种 SETI@home 之类的东西。你可以访问你的医疗记录，但当你这样做时，
tiny piece of the database and i don't know that's weird and cool and i like it yeah i mean if i think if uh if google.com ran like a little bit of the SETI program, we'd be talking to aliens right now. We would have found them. That's interesting. So if you went to go search something, you would have to contribute some portion of work before you could get your result. Yeah, and I think people are working on stuff like that,
它们在 JavaScript 中治愈或检测癌症之类的。这很奇怪，因为它引入了一个外部性。我喜欢你需要为服务完成一部分必要工作的想法。因为在这个关于运行服务成本的想法中，我可能不必针对你投放那么多广告。好吧，也许他们仍然想赚钱。
sort of similar, I guess, like with Bitcoin and all this weird blockchain stuff and distributed trust, basically. And I don't know, I guess we're just at the beginning of that, too. And we'll see if it ends up working on a large scale for things like a distributed search engine. I think mathematically it seems like it's possible, but I guess we'll see how it's implemented that would be pretty cool like you uh yeah you get access to some service but only if you you know let your computer crunch numbers for a little bit there's something cool about that especially if it was some type of i mean seti at home kind of thing um you know like you can access your medical records, but while you're doing it,
但理论上你可以运行一个非营利组织，比如 archive.org，但如果你要使用 archive.org，你就需要去为它爬取一些网站。是的，这有点像带有比例限制的 BitTorrent。是的，但困难的部分在于，你如何验证用户归档的内容是正确的，以及你如何防止串通的坏人破坏你的东西？这涉及到很多奇怪的事情。我们上集谈到了零知识证明，那是答案的一部分。是的，这可能是相关的。是的，没错。所以我们实际上已经尝试解释过两次 Docker 了，两次都收到了仇恨邮件，人们告诉我们我们不知道自己在说什么，所以
they're like curing, you know, detecting cancer or something in JavaScript. That's weird because it brings in an externality. I like that you need to do a portion of the work necessary for the service. Because in this idea of like the cost to run the service, I may not have to run as many ads against you. Well, maybe they still want to make money.
所以我不会尝试第三次了，我要把这个留给 Daniel，我会把所有的仇恨邮件转发给你。所以你能试着向我们和其他不知道的人解释一下 Docker 吗？我的意思是，我们很了解虚拟机、VirtualBox 之类的东西，但 Docker 与之有何不同？与你的操作系统有何不同？好的，我可能会犯一些错误，所以我先把我的仇恨邮件收件箱热身一下。好的，成就解锁。是的，据我所知，我们实际上在 HyperDev 的一部分上使用了 Docker。我眼中的 Docker 是，它所做的一切以前在各个部分中都已经完成过了。它提供了关于机器上资源限制的某些东西。它提供了像沙盒文件系统这样的东西，
But you could in theory run like a not- for profit something like archive.org but you need to go crawl some website for archive.org if you're going to use archive.org yeah it's kind of like bittorrent with the ratios and all of that yeah yeah and the hard part though then is then how do you validate what the person archived is the right thing and how do you prevent groups of colluding bad actors from corrupting your thing and it gets into a lot of kind of weird talked about zero knowledge proofs we had about zero knowledge proofs last episode that's true that's part of the answer yeah it could be it could be relevant yeah that's right the so you know we have we've actually tried to explain docker twice and both times we've gotten hate mail for people who uh tell us we don't know what we're talking about so
与机器的其他部分隔离。它提供了有限的权限和对主机机器资源的访问。但它让 Docker 术语中的这些容器运行得就像它们是自己的整个机器一样。所以它们不一定知道它们只是更大机器的一个沙盒部分。它还有一些像 Docker 文件这样的东西来指定配置以及如何设置程序和应用程序的需求。所以它基本上把许多已经存在的东西联系在一起，
so i'm not going to try and do it a third time i'm going to leave this up to daniel uh and i'm going to forward all the hate mail to you so can you try to explain docker to uh to us and to other people who uh who don't you know i mean we know vms pretty well virtual box and all of that um but sort of how is docker kind of different than that different than your os things like that all right i'll probably uh make some mistakes so uh i'll get my hate mail inbox warmed up all right achievement unlocked yeah uh so i guess as i understand it we are actually using docker on part of hyperdev uh and so the way i see it is it's sort of all the things that docker does have been done before in various pieces. So it provides certain things about resource constraints that you can have on a machine. It provides things like a sandboxed file system
但通过一个更好的 API，并将它们全部联系成一个连贯的单元，你可以将其作为工具带的一部分来解决你的一些问题。酷，希望这有点道理。是的，完全有道理。那么有人使用 Docker 的原因有哪些呢？好吧，我可以告诉你我们使用 Docker 的原因，它可能与许多人的应用程序有点不同，但我会从那里开始。我们在 HyperDev 上使用 Docker。
that's isolated from the rest of the machine. It provides things with limited permissions and access to the host machine's resources. But it lets these containers in Docker parlance run as if they were their own entire machine. So they don't necessarily know that they're just a sandboxed portion of a larger machine. And it also has some things with like Docker files to specify configuration and how to set up the requirements for your programs and applications. So it basically ties together many things that have existed,
我想对于那些不知道的人，HyperDev 是一个你可以访问的网站。它在浏览器中有一个编辑器。在你到达 hyperdev.com 两秒钟后，我们已经启动了一个运行你代码的应用程序。你的代码在编辑器中，
but with like a nicer API and ties them all together into a coherent unit that you can then use as part of your tool belt to solve some of your problems cool hopefully that made a little bit of sense yeah totally yeah totally so so what are some reasons why someone would use docker well let's see i can tell you our reasons of why we're using docker uh it's a little bit different than maybe many people's applications, but I'll start with that. So we use Docker on HyperDev.
你可以输入更改，它会立即在你的应用程序中重新加载。它在互联网上是实时的。任何其他人都可以访问它并看到你写的内容。为了非常快速地启动这样的东西，我们使用 Docker 容器镜像，
I guess for those who don't know, HyperDev, it's a website you can go to. It has an editor in the browser. And in two seconds after you get there at hyperdev.com, we've already launched an application running your code. And your code's in the editor,
一个 Docker 镜像来启动容器。该镜像基本上有 Node.js 和你的应用程序可能需要的所有这些操作系统级工具。该镜像就像应用程序的蓝图。我们只需获取该镜像，在上面放一个很小的层，即
you can type in changes and it immediately reloads in your application. It's live on the internet. Anyone else can go to it and see what you've written. So in order to launch something like that very quickly, we use a Docker container image,
你的应用程序代码，然后它就会运行你的应用程序。它可以在几秒钟内启动。而如果你想启动一个虚拟机，甚至是一个虚拟服务器或物理服务器，这些东西启动需要更长的时间，因为它们试图模拟的栈块更大。所以 Docker 模拟的是那种仍然看起来像拥有完整机器的最小块。明白了。
a Docker image to launch the container. And the image basically has Node.js and all these operating system level tools that your apps might need. And that image is sort of like the blueprint for the application. And we just take that image, put in a little tiny layer on top that's
所以这就是，如果你去 HyperDev（我们稍后会更详细地讨论），但如果你去 hyperdev.com，它会给你这台机器，如果你删除了所有文件，比如试图搞坏这台机器，你最多只能破坏这个 Docker 容器，然后它就会进入某个深渊被忽略。是的。所以理论上，Docker 提供的安全性足够强大，你无法逃离沙盒并搞乱
your application code, and then it runs your application. And it can come up in just a couple of seconds. Whereas if you want to spin up a VM or even a virtual server or even a physical server, those things would take a lot longer to spin up because they're sort of larger chunks of the stack that they're trying to simulate. And so Docker sort of is simulating kind of the smallest chunk that still gives the appearance of having a full machine. Gotcha.
在同一节点或同一机器上运行的其他人的应用程序。总是可能存在安全漏洞，所以我们必须掌握所有这些。但就像虚拟机甚至共享主机一样，保持安全始终是一个问题。
And so that's how, if you go to HyperDev, which we'll talk about definitely in much more detail later but if you go to hyperdev.com it gives you this machine and if you delete all the files like try to like you know you know bork the machine up the worst you could do is break this docker container which then goes into the abyss somewhere is ignored yep. So the theory is that the security provided by Docker is strong enough that you can't escape from your sandbox and mess up
我认为，正如我之前所说，Docker 的抽象现在是那种最轻量级的，让你感觉你的应用拥有整台机器。是的，太酷了。所以我们谈到了只做客户端的网站，但如果我们回归常态，谈谈大多数网站，你有
other people's applications running on the same node or on the same machine. It's always possible that there could be security exploits so we have to stay on top of all of that. But just like with VMs or even on shared hosts, it's always been an issue is staying on top of security.
一个服务器，你可能在 Amazon 上购买了一个实例，运行着 MySQL 数据库。而且，比如经典的 LAMP 栈，对吧？你有一些网站，你在上面对世界上发生的各种事件进行投注。这是最新的风潮，对吧？有所有这些网站，你可以去对随机的事情进行投注。是的，预测市场。没错，正是这样。所以你运行自己的预测市场服务器，
And I think, you know, it's just a different, like I said earlier, the abstraction with Docker is now sort of the lightest weight thing that gives you the experience of imagining your app has the full machine to itself yeah very cool so uh we talked about you know doing doing client only uh websites but uh if we revert back to the mean and talk about you know most uh websites where you have
它有几个用户，你的妈妈，你的家人，你的朋友。是的，在美国别那样做。是的，如果你这样做，你会坐牢。但你不是，你在瑞典之类的。但突然之间，每个人都知道了你的服务器，它就开始爆炸了。人们给你写了大量的电子邮件说：“怎么回事，我无法访问网站。”
a server you know you you're maybe buying a, you know, instance on Amazon, where you're running my SQL database. And, you know, let's say the canonical LAMP stack, right? And you have some website where you're doing, you know, you're doing betting on different events happening in the world. This is like the latest rage, right? There are all these sites where you can go and bet on just random things. Yeah, prediction markets. That's right, exactly. So you're running your own prediction market server,
你去那里发现磁盘满了，它正在崩溃。你如何扩展它？你去那里发现磁盘满了，它正在崩溃，你如何扩展它？这是你可以快速做到的事情吗？如果你处于那种紧急情况，这是你必须计划的，需要几周或几个月吗？你实际上怎么能做到这一点？好吧，我想我的建议是，快速做到这一点并不容易。通常发生的情况是，没有小开关可以拨动说：“好的，因为我按了那个按钮，我的服务器现在扩展了。”
and it has a few users, your mom, your family, your friends. Yeah, don't do that in the United States. Yeah, yeah, if you do this, you're going to jail. But you're not, you're in Sweden or something. But then all of a sudden, everyone finds out about your server, and it just starts blowing up. People are writing you tons of emails saying, what's going on, I can't get on the website.
有时你可以多付钱获得更大的实例或更大的数据库，那可以维持一段时间。但如果你只是把东西翻倍，如果你的流量是 100 倍或 1000 倍，那仍然不够。它肯定会在高峰期淹没你。但我认为一夜成名相当罕见，即使……好吧，那不是真的。确实有发布日会产生巨大影响。
You go there and you find the disk is just maxed out and it's just falling apart. How do you sort of scale that up? you go there and you find like the disc is just maxed out and it's just falling apart like how do you sort of scale that up is that something you can do quickly you know if you're in that kind of emergency is that something you have to plan for that takes you know weeks or months and and what how can you actually make that happen uh let's see i guess my advice on it is it's not really easy to do it quickly. Usually what happens is there's no little switch you can throw to say, okay, my server is now scaled up because I pushed that button.
但通常网站只是爆炸了。然后你恢复一点并修复最大的问题。扩展不是一个单一的事件。这是一个过程，你处于某种规模，并且有某种流量预期。偶尔，你可能会遇到一个大的高峰或大的事情。它可能会暂时让你的网站
Sometimes you can pay more money and get a bigger instance or bigger database, and that'll go for a little while. But if you're just doubling things, that's still not that much more than if your traffic is like 100 times or 1,000 times. It'll definitely swamp you on the spikes. But I think the overnight success is pretty rare, even, well, that's not true. There are launch days that have a big impact and things.
宕机，但它通常会回到你之前的水平，也许稍微高一点。所以这不是一次性的事件，你启动你的网站，现在它很受欢迎，有一百万用户。那些人必须来自某个地方，他们通常来自你已经拥有的用户。所以你一点一点地增加它。当你遇到问题时，你可以尝试一个一个地解决它们。就像你可以分析你的应用程序，
But usually the site just blows up. Then you recover a little bit and fix the biggest problems. Scaling isn't a single event. It's a process where you're at a certain scale and you have a certain traffic expectation. Every once in a while, you maybe get a big spike or a big thing that comes in. It might knock your site
你可以看到：“哦，我们正在向磁盘写入大量数据，我们每天写入这么多，而且还在增长。”所以你可以计算你还剩下多少磁盘空间，并清楚地知道你至少必须在下周之前修复它。是的，这是一个非常好的观点。我认为有时我们低估了，或者我们少报了你花在看图表上的时间。人们认为你是软件工程师，你只是在敲代码，他们看电影，认为你一直在 SSH，
down temporarily but it will generally return kind of back to what your level was before but maybe a little bit higher and so it's not like a one-time event where you start your site and now it's popular and has a million users like those people had to come from somewhere and they usually came from the users you already have so you grow it a little at a time. And as you hit problems, you can try and solve them one by one usually as you're growing. Like you can profile your application
矩阵是这种霓虹绿色的文字飞过。但现实是你花了很多时间看数据并说：“哦，我的网站就是这样增长的。这就是我必须为未来做计划的方式。”是的，就像上周我看了 HyperDev 服务器上的磁盘空间使用情况，它是 50%，我想：“好的，我还有点时间。”我今天看了它们，它是 80%，我想：“好的，我最好开始为此做点什么。”你知道，也许明天。太棒了。所以，有 LAMP 栈，你有一台强力的机器，上面有一个大型数据库，然后你也有你建议的这些平台即服务（PaaS）架构。
and you can see, oh, we're writing a lot of data to the disk and we're writing this much every day and it's still growing. So you can count how much disk space you have left and have a pretty good idea that you have to fix it at least you know by the next week uh yeah that's a really good point i think i think sometimes we underestimate or we we under announce really how much time you spend looking at graphs like people think you're a software engineer you're just like banging away code and you know they they watch the movies and they think you're constantly like SSH
有人在托管你的服务器，另一个人可能是 Docker 容器，或者通过 AWS，通过 Dynamo 等等。优缺点是什么？在你的机器上运行 MySQL 服务器是否已经过时了，还是有优势？每个人都应该转向其中之一吗？
and the Matrix is this neon green text going flying by. But the reality is you spend a lot of time looking at data and saying, oh, this is how my website is growing. This is sort of how I have to plan for the future and things like that. Yeah, just like last week i looked at the disk space usage on some hyperdev servers and it's like at 50 i'm like okay i've got a little time i looked at them today and it's like at 80 i'm like okay this is i better start doing something about this you know maybe tomorrow that's awesome so um so there's you know the the sort of lamp stack where you have you know one you know beefy machine um that has like one large database on it and then you also have kind of as you suggested these sort of um you know these
权衡是什么？我认为运行带有应用程序的数据库服务器可能永远不会过时。它之所以首先流行，是因为有一定的简单性。你可以在本地开发机器上设置，你可以安装 MySQL 或 Postgres，你可以安装 Apache，你可以安装 PHP。
these kind of platforms a platform as a service type of architecture, you know, these kind of platforms, platform as a service type of architecture, where, you know, one sort of person's hosting your server, another person's, it could be a Docker container, or it could be through AWS, through Dynamo and all these things. What are sort of the pros and cons? Like is running a MySQL server on your, on, you know, just kind of obsolete or is there still an advantage to that? You know, should everyone move to one or the other?
他们甚至有一键安装程序，可以设置好一切。通过添加 Docker 或其他服务，你可以稍微转移一些随之而来的复杂性。但如果你只是把 Postgres 换成 Docker 化的 Postgres，你仍然是在安装一个东西。
What are sort of the trade-offs there? I think running a database server with your application will probably never be obsolete. Like there's a certain simplicity as to why it was popular in the first place. Like you can just get set up on your local development machine you can install MySQL or Postgres you can install Apache you can install PHP
你现在需要安装 Docker 而不是 Postgres。只有当你有很多东西要换成较少的东西时，它才真正值得。所以 Web 服务器和 Web 应用程序仍然像 Node 应用、Ruby on Rails 或 PHP 应用一样，它们仍然足够简单，把一切都放在虚拟机或 Docker 中，如果你刚开始，并不总是能占到便宜。所以我说不要太担心，做最容易开始的事情。然后稍后，当你遇到问题时，你可以一个一个地解决它们。这很有道理。所以对于一个可能在高中，
they even have one-click installers that set it all up and it's sort of getting there's some complexity that comes with that that you can move around a little bit by adding Docker or other services. But if you just swap out Postgres for a Dockerized Postgres, you still have one thing you're installing.
正在学习 AP 计算机科学，第三周，他们写了 Hello World，他们想建立一个网站，谈论 Minecraft 之类的东西，你如何从零开始？是的，我想这取决于你的目标是否只是拥有一个网站，比如论坛之类的。很多共享主机，你可以只获得一个域名，获得一些托管，点击一个按钮，然后砰，你在互联网上就有了一个论坛。这并不能真正教你它是如何工作的，但它确实让你的东西建立起来了。
You still now need to install Docker instead of Postgres. It really only pays off if you have many things that you're swapping out for fewer things uh and so web servers are and web applications are still like a node app or a ruby on rails or php apps like they're still simple enough that putting everything in a VM or putting everything into Docker, you don't always come out ahead for apps if you're just getting started. So I'd say don't worry too much about it and just do what's the easiest thing to get started. And then later, you can solve those problems one at a time as you encounter them. That makes sense. So for somebody who's maybe uh in high school they
你可以自定义样式。是的，只要你有源代码的访问权限，这是一个很好的观点。你可以从 PHPBB 或这些一键安装程序之一开始，然后你不可避免地会遇到：“哦，我真的想在我的论坛上放 Minecraft 徽章。让我去编辑一些代码。”这可以让你进入状态。
they're taking ap computer science they're on week three they wrote hello world and uh they want to build you know a website uh where they can talk about minecraft or or something like that how how do you get started like from from from zero? Yeah, I guess it depends on if your goal is to just have a website, like a forum or something. A lot of shared hosts, you can just get a domain, get some hosting, and click a button, and then boom, you've got a forum on the internet. And that doesn't really teach you how it all works, but it sort of gets your thing built up.
是的，绝对。这些天实际上变得有点困难，因为一切都比以前复杂了。网站更大，应用程序更大。有更多的层和更多的组件。很难找到像以前那样简单且易于修改的东西，尽管也许从来没有一个简单的时代，这只是回顾过去，觉得“哦，是的，过去的好日子，事情很简单”，但我不知道。
You can kind of customize the styles. Yeah, and as long as you have access to the source code, that's a good point. You could start off with PHP BB or one of these one-click install, and then invariably you'll run into, oh, I really want Minecraft badges on my forum. Let me go and edit some code. And that can kind of get you into it.
现在打开东西并深入研究，做一点小改动并看到它起作用似乎更难了。不，我同意。我的意思是人们总是写信问：“嘿，我想制作下一款最畅销的视频游戏，我该如何开始？”这就像，编写一款最畅销的视频游戏非常……你指出的那样，非常复杂。我们认为比以前复杂得多。我不知道这是否是真的，但感觉你需要学习更多的技术来编写 3D 第一人称射击游戏或大型多人游戏。这看起来有点像你说的，即使我想运行一个论坛，那很容易。你可以直接使用现成的。
Yeah, definitely. It's actually getting kind of tough these days because everything is like more complicated than it used to be. Like websites are bigger, applications are bigger. There's more layers and there's more components. And it's like hard to find things that are as simple and as hackable although maybe there was never a time when it was simple and it's just like looking back it's like oh yeah the good old days and things are simple but i don't know
是的，绝对是这样。实际上这些天变得有点困难，因为一切都比过去复杂多了。比如网站变得更庞大，应用程序也更庞大。层级更多，组件也更多。很难找到像以前那样简单且易于修改的东西，尽管也许从来就没有过什么简单的时代，只是回首往事时会觉得“哦，那是美好的旧时光，一切都很简单”，但我也不确定。
it just seems like it's harder to open stuff up now and like dig into it and make a little change and see that it works no i agree i mean people always write and ask you know hey i want to build the next best-selling video game you know how do i get started uh and it's like well writing a best-selling video game is very like you're kind of pointing it's very complicated you know we think kind of much more than it used to be uh i don't know if that's actually true or not but it feels there's many more technologies you need to learn, you know, to write a 3D first person shooter or a massively multiplayer game. And it seems kind of like what you're saying, like, even if you I want to run a forum, that's easy. You can just run one off the shelf.
现在似乎更难去拆解东西、深入研究、做一点小改动并看到效果了。不，我同意你的看法。人们总是写信问我：“嘿，我想开发下一款畅销电子游戏，我该如何入门？”这就像是……写一款畅销游戏非常复杂，比过去复杂得多。我不知道这是否属实，但感觉确实如此。你需要学习更多的技术，才能编写一款3D第一人称射击游戏或大型多人在线游戏。这似乎和你说的很像，即使我想运营一个论坛，那很容易，直接用现成的就行。
But if you say I want to learn about how to write these apps, building an easy app. I mean, I guess if you're trying to build something that is the equivalent of another thing, the amount of technologies you have to learn does seem to be growing or you have to be able to do more because people expect more from a web service. I wonder if I wonder if this is sort of just part of progress. And I wonder if maybe the answer is that we have to do more encapsulation right like for example i have no idea um like how like you know assembly you know stuff works and branch prediction i mean i could guess but but i mean i if if you told me to write a compiler that actually produced an executable that could run in windows like i have no idea how to do that and uh um it's just it that has become like a very specialized skill and and compilers have become so incredibly complex that if you wanted to make big improvements to gcc or something you have to be a total wizard but but
但如果你说你想学习如何编写这些应用程序，构建一个简单的应用。我的意思是，我想如果你试图构建一个相当于其他东西的东西，你必须学习的技术数量似乎在增加，或者你必须能够做更多的事情，因为人们对网络服务有更高的期望。我想知道这是否只是进步的一部分。我想知道答案是否是我们必须做更多的封装，比如，我完全不知道汇编语言是如何工作的，也不知道分支预测，我的意思是，我可以猜测，但如果你让我编写一个能在 Windows 上运行的可执行文件的编译器，我完全不知道该怎么做，这已经成为一种非常专业的技能，而且编译器已经变得如此复杂，如果你想对 GCC 之类的东西进行重大改进，你必须是一个彻头彻尾的专家。
then what happened is people kind of moved up in the stack. And I feel like with games, it's the same thing. Like the games, you could say, oh, you know, if I was back in the Atari days, I could make a whole game by myself, including writing all the source code, building the whole engine. Like, you know, Pitfall and Asteroids are written by one or two people, you know with the engine and everything um but now you still have you know one person two person game development companies but they're just not making the engine they're just using unity that's a good point yeah and so so now it's like all the one person game studios are strictly focused on content and uh and and and showing like a new type of pattern that's appealing. To phrase your original question a little differently, I mean, I guess when you don't know, you don't know what you don't know.
然后发生的事情是人们在技术栈上向上移动了。我觉得游戏也是一样。就像游戏，你可以说，哦，你知道，如果我回到雅达利时代，我可以自己制作整个游戏，包括编写所有源代码，构建整个引擎。就像《Pitfall》和《Asteroids》是由一两个人编写的，包括引擎和所有东西。但现在你仍然有一人或两人的游戏开发公司，但他们只是不制作引擎，他们只是在使用 Unity。这是一个很好的观点，是的，所以现在所有的一人游戏工作室都严格专注于内容，并展示一种吸引人的新模式。为了以不同的方式表达你最初的问题，我的意思是，我想当你不知道的时候，你不知道你不知道什么。
Oh, that was profound. Unconscious ignorance, that's what it's called. And so when you're starting out, you're in AP computer science, you aren't in the field. It's very difficult to know what's hard and what's easy. And that's kind of cool because you don't know what you aren't in the field, it's very difficult to know what's hard and what's easy. And that's kind of cool, because you don't know what you shouldn't be tackling. Like you said, you may not know that a compiler is really hard. And so you can go tackle it. And there's a certain kind of awesomeness in there. But I guess like what as a group do we think is a good recommendation for, hey, this is an appropriately sized web project to work on, where you can get your hands dirty at an appropriate level for starting out
哦，那太深刻了。无意识的无知，这就是所谓的。所以当你刚开始的时候，你在学习 AP 计算机科学，你不在这个领域。很难知道什么是难的，什么是容易的。这很酷，因为你不知道你不应该处理什么。就像你说的，你可能不知道编译器真的很难。所以你可以去尝试它。这其中有一种很棒的感觉。但我猜作为一个群体，我们认为什么是好的建议，嘿，这是一个适合初学者上手练习的合适规模的网络项目。
well let's see i think the trick is just to not worry about it because if you start trying to figure out what's like the right thing like you're just over analyzing it you have something you want to do just do it and try and do it as simply as you can like find whatever the first thing is that seems like it might work and just try it out and really experiment, dig into it like it is going to be totally overwhelming and confusing at first
嗯，让我们看看，我认为诀窍就是不要担心它，因为如果你开始试图弄清楚什么是正确的事情，你只是在过度分析。你有想做的事情，就去做，并尽可能简单地去做。找到任何看起来可能有效的第一件事，然后试一试，真正去实验，深入研究它。起初它会让人感到完全不知所措和困惑。
but it might not be, you might just luck out and it will work out but if you analyze what's the perfect piece of work, it kind of distracts you from whatever your goal is. Like you're trying to use computers to solve a problem. I think there is no glory in using computers
但也许不会，你可能会走运，它会成功。但如果你分析什么是完美的作品，它会分散你对目标的注意力。就像你试图用计算机解决问题一样。我认为使用计算机并没有什么荣耀可言。
just to be good at using computers. Like that's kind of a, it might help you accomplish other things, but it's those other things that matter. Yeah, it's a good point. That's a good way to look at it. Yeah, I think that, you know, if people get into computers, you know, I mean, there are some people who get into,
仅仅是擅长使用计算机。这可能有助于你完成其他事情，但重要的是那些其他事情。是的，这是一个很好的观点。这是一个很好的看待方式。是的，我认为，你知道，如果人们进入计算机领域，我的意思是，有些人进入，
let's say, let's say video game development. There's people who get into that because they like video games. They like the outcome. But there are a lot of people who get into software engineering or development just because they like building things and they like seeing code run really fast and things like that. And so what happens is when they do a personal project, they try to optimize what they like and not sort of what they want, which are kind of two different things like i mean if you write a really awesome game engine that might that feels kind of good in like this visceral way like you see oh look at these triangles and they're so fast and and all these
比如说，视频游戏开发。有些人进入这个领域是因为他们喜欢视频游戏。他们喜欢结果。但有很多人进入软件工程或开发领域只是因为他们喜欢构建东西，喜欢看到代码运行得非常快等等。所以当他们做个人项目时，他们会试图优化他们喜欢的，而不是他们想要的，这其实是两码事。我的意思是，如果你编写了一个非常棒的游戏引擎，那感觉很好，有一种发自内心的感觉，就像你看到，哦，看这些三角形，它们跑得这么快，还有所有这些
things um but if but if you if you set out to make a video game and you say, I'm going to build this really fast engine, then you're kind of serving yourself, which is fine. But that's often not what people think is going to happen. I mean, people set out to make some game because they want to deliver a certain experience. And then they end up with three years of building something they think is cool. And then three years later, they haven't even started delivering the experience. And so I think to your point, like, it's, you know, it kind of is innate to people who are analytical to say, Oh, I need to find the best possible game engine. I mean, there's so many websites dedicated to what's the best game engine, or, you know, what's the best database database there's like so many wars over mongo db
东西。但如果你着手制作一个视频游戏，你说，我要构建这个非常快的引擎，那么你是在为自己服务，这没问题。但这通常不是人们认为会发生的事情。我的意思是，人们着手制作某个游戏是因为他们想提供某种体验。然后他们最终花了三年时间构建他们认为很酷的东西。三年后，他们甚至还没有开始提供那种体验。所以我认为回到你的观点，对于分析型的人来说，这是一种天性，他们会说，哦，我需要找到最好的游戏引擎。我的意思是，有太多的网站致力于讨论什么是最好的游戏引擎，或者什么是最好的数据库，关于 MongoDB 有太多的争论。
couch db and all these people just writing paragraph after paragraph but really just like pick something and just you know go with it and then only if you feel like you've made just a grave error should you really turn around and and if you're picking something popular that's going to be very rare uh that that you pick something that just completely fails you yeah definitely i think uh it's important when you're starting to do something especially if you think oh my goal is to build a game and then you spend years on it like you may have committed too early to building a game you just say oh if my goal is unexplore using Unity, and just how does it work?
CouchDB 以及所有这些人写了一段又一段的文字，但实际上只是选择一个并坚持下去，只有当你觉得你犯了一个严重的错误时，你才应该回头。如果你选择的是流行的东西，那么你选择的东西完全失败的情况是非常罕见的。是的，绝对的。我认为当你开始做某事时，这很重要，特别是如果你认为哦，我的目标是构建一个游戏，然后你花了几年时间在上面，你可能过早地致力于构建一个游戏。你只需要说，哦，如果我的目标是探索 Unity，它到底是怎么工作的？
And you start messing around with it, and then you can kind of get a feeling for what you actually want to do. Whereas if you commit from day one, knowing nothing about it, I'm going to build the best first-person shooter. That can commit you to a path that is very challenging and possibly not as rewarding as you thought.
你开始摆弄它，然后你就能对你真正想做的事情有一种感觉。而如果你从第一天开始，在对它一无所知的情况下就承诺说，我要构建最好的第一人称射击游戏。这会让你走上一条非常具有挑战性的道路，而且可能并不像你想象的那样有回报。
Or if you just go with an open mind, think, I want to explore this. What can I do in this system? What is the world like today? What does this tool enable me to do? And kind of follow it. It'll lead you to things. And then maybe once you know a little more,
或者如果你只是带着开放的心态，想，我想探索这个。我能在这个系统中做什么？今天的世界是什么样的？这个工具能让我做什么？并跟随它。它会引导你走向某些事物。然后也许当你了解更多一点时，
you can have some idea about what type of game or the scope of the project you can undertake. And just being open to being lost like being a beginner which is why kids can learn so fast actually they don't necessarily have a strict goal in mind or if they do they can change their mind very often to explore new things yeah that's a really good point because often you know what motivates uh people is is when they see something and they think they could do better. You know, there's a lot of people who have a very good eye for, let's say, a very good eye for, a very good ear for music, and they hear a song and they say, oh, you know, I could make that song better. And you might have
你可以对你能承担的游戏类型或项目范围有一些想法。保持开放的心态去迷失，就像一个初学者，这就是为什么孩子们学得这么快，他们不一定有一个严格的目标，或者如果他们有，他们可以经常改变主意去探索新事物。是的，这是一个很好的观点，因为通常激励人们的是当他们看到某些东西并认为他们可以做得更好时。你知道，有很多人对音乐有很好的眼光，或者说有很好的耳朵，他们听到一首歌，然后说，哦，你知道，我可以把那首歌做得更好。你可能
a good eye for game design, and you might play, you might play the new Doom, and you might say, oh, I could do this better. But then if you make that your goal, that's going to be very hard. Take this AAA title and make it better. Unless you work there, that's's very unattainable goal i think it's much better to um kind of as daniel suggested um just kind of just kind of let yourself be creative and don't uh try to focus on that kind of incremental uh you know advances yeah a lot of games actually have a pretty big modding community and some of them are still easy to mod like the developers design them in a way to be more easily modifiable and so if you do like you see a game you're like i could make this better
对游戏设计有很好的眼光，你可能会玩新的《Doom》，然后你可能会说，哦，我可以做得更好。但如果你把这作为你的目标，那将是非常困难的。拿这个 3A 级大作并让它变得更好。除非你在那里工作，否则这是一个非常难以实现的目标。我认为最好还是像 Daniel 建议的那样，让自己有创造力，不要试图专注于那种渐进式的进步。是的，很多游戏实际上有一个相当大的模组社区，其中一些仍然很容易修改，因为开发者设计它们的方式使它们更容易被修改。所以如果你看到一个游戏，你觉得我可以做得更好，
then you can like look for a mod that maybe does the same thing or something similar and like crack open the mod and change it a little bit and like you can make it better and it can be better for you and better for people who share your aesthetic yeah that's a good point it's a good point yeah and if if the mod you know if you if you have to make you know your your my little pony video game with with doom characters then you know that's what you do to to get the prototype out and get the message out yeah and like as you uh expand your skills and like get more and more ambitious you'll naturally run to the limits of your tool and you'll have to look farther like bigger things more powerful tools
那么你可以寻找一个可能做同样事情或类似事情的模组，然后打开模组并稍微修改一下，你可以让它变得更好，这对你和分享你审美的人来说都会更好。是的，这是一个很好的观点。是的，如果你必须制作你的《小马宝莉》视频游戏，里面有《Doom》的角色，那么这就是你为了拿出原型并传达信息所做的事情。是的，随着你扩展技能并变得越来越有野心，你会自然地达到工具的极限，你将不得不寻找更远的东西，比如更大的东西，更强大的工具。
learn more knowledge and it's like a natural process yeah patrick yeah did you oh i was just i was gonna side rail the topic i was gonna say that uh you're talking about modding have you guys seen the crazy mods people do in the grand theft auto and the like photorealistic graphics mods oh no i saw the mod where you can fly which which makes the game actually like very different because you just fly from checkpoint checkpoint just playing the missions oh yeah i need to say someone where they yeah yeah that just seems like a different game yeah okay but that was a complete side topic
学习更多的知识，这是一个自然的过程。是的，Patrick，你是要偏离主题吗？我是说，你刚才谈到模组，你们见过人们在《侠盗猎车手》中做的那些疯狂的模组吗，比如照片级逼真的图形模组？哦，没有，我看到过那个可以飞行的模组，这让游戏变得非常不同，因为你只是从一个检查点飞到另一个检查点，直接玩任务。哦，是的，我需要告诉某人。是的，那看起来就像一个不同的游戏。好的，但这完全是一个题外话。
yeah it's okay actually so not to spend too much on this but there's there is the flying mod which basically breaks the game or changes it dramatically but there's a hulk mod where you can turn into the hulk pick up cars and throw them at people and that also breaks the game, but it is extremely entertaining.
是的，没关系。实际上，为了不在这上面花太多时间，有一个飞行模组，它基本上破坏了游戏或极大地改变了它，但还有一个绿巨人模组，你可以变成绿巨人，捡起汽车并把它们扔向人们，这也破坏了游戏，但它非常有趣。
If you don't want to go through the trouble of installing it, just watch it on YouTube. It's very funny. It'd be cool if they incorporate that Hulk mod into the next game. It's like there's a science lab or whatever, and it's just like a temporary thing for one level. Oh, yeah, that'd be awesome. Yeah, that's amazing yeah the uh i'm waiting for the i want a mod for minecraft where it would take random people on the internet it would take like things they've built and put it into my game
如果你不想费心去安装它，就在 YouTube 上看吧。它非常有趣。如果他们能把那个绿巨人模组整合到下一个游戏中会很酷。就像有一个科学实验室什么的，这只是一个关卡中的临时东西。哦，是的，那太棒了。是的，这太神奇了。是的，我在等，我想要一个《Minecraft》的模组，它可以随机抓取互联网上的人，抓取他们建造的东西并放入我的游戏中。
and vice versa i think the dark souls for minecraft yeah yeah exactly what are you waiting for you you are a computer engineer dude go do this i know i need to build this you know how to write code yes that's true um so uh so you talked about hyperdev a little bit um and you mentioned you work at fog creek so well first like what is what is fog creek um what do you guys what's sort of your mission uh you work on hyperdev what other things uh does your company work on and what's what's it all about yeah so at fog creek we try and make uh life much better for developers like really give developers great tools to do their jobs. So we have Fogbugs for issue tracking.
反之亦然，我想《Minecraft》的《黑暗之魂》模组。是的，完全正确。你还在等什么？你是一个计算机工程师，伙计，去实现它吧。我知道，我需要构建它。你知道怎么写代码吗？是的，那是真的。那么，你谈到了一点 HyperDev，你提到你在 Fog Creek 工作。那么首先，什么是 Fog Creek？你们的使命是什么？你从事 HyperDev 工作，你们公司还从事什么其他工作？这一切是关于什么的？是的，在 Fog Creek，我们试图让开发者的生活变得更好，真正为开发者提供伟大的工具来完成他们的工作。所以我们有 FogBugz 用于问题跟踪。
We actually were the company where Stack Overflow started out. It's now split out to its own company. And we also were the company where Trello started, and Trello is now also split out to its own company. So our main goal is helping the world's best developers to do the best work they can uh and hyper dev is trying to expand that a little further to not like just necessarily software developers who work as software developers but just anybody who has a problem
我们实际上是 Stack Overflow 起步的公司。它现在已经分拆成一家独立的公司。我们也是 Trello 起步的公司，Trello 现在也分拆成了一家独立的公司。所以我们的主要目标是帮助世界上最好的开发者完成他们能做的最好的工作。HyperDev 试图将这一点进一步扩展，不一定只是针对作为软件开发者的软件开发者，而是针对任何有问题的人。
they need to solve using a computer because everything's on the internet, everything's in various APIs and services, and you just want the computer to help you solve your problem. You don't want to necessarily mess around with, oh, I need to install Node, but the operating system version of Node
他们需要使用计算机来解决问题，因为一切都在互联网上，一切都在各种 API 和服务中，你只是想让计算机帮助你解决问题。你不一定想摆弄，哦，我需要安装 Node，但操作系统版本的 Node
is incompatible with this library, and now i got to install a different version and you spend all day trying to set up your environment when you just want to like get this api and then post a cat photo somewhere so um so like why would someone um why would someone use hyperdev Which I think is, we've already covered that a little bit, but just and also why would someone, what are sort of the limitations of HyperDev? Like when would you say, okay, I can't use this anymore? Yeah, I think HyperDev would be a great
与这个库不兼容，现在我得安装一个不同的版本，你花了一整天时间试图设置你的环境，而你只是想获取这个 API，然后把一张猫的照片发布到某个地方。所以，为什么有人会使用 HyperDev？我想我们已经讨论过一点了，但还有，为什么有人会使用它？HyperDev 的局限性是什么？什么时候你会说，好吧，我不能再用这个了？是的，我认为 HyperDev 对那些了解一点 JavaScript 或刚开始学习的人来说是一个很好的
first step for people who either know a little bit of JavaScript or are just starting to learn. Say if you have trouble figuring out all these arcane command line things to install and set up your environment, but you've always wanted to have your app run in, you can go to HyperDev. It's running
第一步。假设你在弄清楚所有这些晦涩的命令行东西来安装和设置环境时遇到困难，但你一直想让你的应用程序运行起来，你可以去 HyperDev。它在
in two seconds. You can start getting into this feedback loop where you change your file, you see how it changes your app, and you can change your file a little more and see how it changes you change it again it breaks this time you just undo it and now it's back to where it was and so like once you get into that loop you can really start exploring like just the coding part which is hard enough without having to spend all day just trying to understand crazy insane stuff that developers thought was really cool at the time and now we're stuck with it from like 40 years ago because it's too late to change it
两秒钟内就能运行。你可以开始进入这个反馈循环，你修改你的文件，你看到它如何改变你的应用程序，你可以再修改一点你的文件，看看它如何改变，你再次修改它，这次它坏了，你只需撤销它，它就回到了原来的样子。所以一旦你进入那个循环，你就可以真正开始探索，仅仅是编码部分，这已经够难了，不需要花一整天时间去试图理解开发者当时认为很酷，而现在我们却因为太晚而无法改变，不得不忍受了 40 年的疯狂东西。
yeah that's how i feel about uh um like so many like vi keys or uh you going to start hate mail. Most of Bash. Like, most of Bash commands. Like, the other day, I needed to output, but it was a big, like, I didn't want to stream it all into one file because it was 11 gig. I wanted to create, you know, a bunch of different files. And there's a Unix command called split, which you just do do split and then you do a file size like in bytes and whenever it gets to that many it creates a new file like a rolling file which is like something i wish i knew you know 20 years ago but it's just like basically there's it made me realize like one how powerful you know unix is and all of that and the core utils but also like how like how poor the
是的，我对 vi 键或 Bash 的大部分内容也有这种感觉。就像，前几天，我需要输出，但它很大，我不想把它全部流式传输到一个文件中，因为它有 11GB。我想创建一堆不同的文件。有一个名为 split 的 Unix 命令，你只需执行 split，然后输入一个字节大小，当它达到那个大小时，它就会创建一个新文件，就像一个滚动文件，这是我 20 年前就希望知道的东西。但这让我意识到，一方面 Unix 和所有核心工具是多么强大，另一方面它的可发现性是多么差，我花了 20 年才找到那个可能在我整个职业生涯中都有用的命令。
discoverability is that it took 20 years for something that probably would have been useful like my entire career you know for me to find that command and so yeah it's almost impossible it's crazy the way we expect people to learn computers. We don't teach anyone these things. You just have to study these arcane tomes and figure it out somehow. But computers now are a billion times more powerful in almost any
所以，是的，这几乎是不可能的。我们期望人们学习计算机的方式太疯狂了。我们不教任何人这些东西。你必须研究这些晦涩的巨著，并以某种方式弄清楚它。但现在的计算机在几乎任何维度上都比以前强大了十亿倍。
dimension. Yet you can't just go to a webpage and then have it like interactive documentation where you type it in and see it work people are starting to do it but it's like still very rare whereas i don't know it just it always makes me kind of uh weird and angry thinking about how hard we make things for ourselves and for other people like on wikipedia so you want to learn learn Fourier transforms where it's like
然而，你不能只是去一个网页，然后拥有交互式文档，你在上面输入并看到它工作。人们开始这样做了，但这仍然非常罕见。我不知道，想到我们让自己和他人变得多么困难，总是让我感到奇怪和愤怒。就像在维基百科上，你想学习傅里叶变换，它是
transforming a sequence of data points from a time series into like a frequency spectrum. And they've got all these little like animated GIFs with little waves
将一系列数据点从时间序列转换为频率谱。他们有所有这些带有小波浪的动画 GIF。
and they like stack them up and you can see how the waves stack up to make the same data points. But like why is it an animated gif why can't i like grab those waves and mess around with them so like really see how it changes the equation and changes the waves and changes the data and just mess with any part of it like it's kind of uh kind of insane that that's not commonplace yeah i mean the problem is i think it's so hard to democratize really anything i mean this is why
他们把它们堆叠起来，你可以看到波浪是如何堆叠起来形成相同数据点的。但为什么它是动画 GIF？为什么我不能抓住那些波浪并摆弄它们，从而真正看到它如何改变方程，改变波浪，改变数据，并摆弄它的任何部分？这简直太疯狂了，这不是常态。是的，我的意思是，我认为民主化任何东西都太难了。我的意思是，这就是为什么
we've had the same gif uh format for so many years right is it's you know and that's why we use email the reason why email well one of the reasons why email is so popular is because i could have some bash script and i could create some output and i could pipe that output to send mail. And I just, I get an email. It's like, you know, it's like baked into Unix for a lot of people. And, and, uh, it's just like the things that have been democratized are so old and it just doesn't seem like there's this winner take all phenomena where if you come up with something better, there's just no way to get any traction. Wait, did you just claim email was popular because you could do it from Unix?
我们这么多年来一直使用相同的 GIF 格式，对吧？这就是为什么我们使用电子邮件。电子邮件流行的原因之一是因为我可以有一个 bash 脚本，我可以创建一些输出，我可以将该输出通过管道传输到 send mail。然后我就收到了一封电子邮件。它就像是为很多人内置在 Unix 中的东西。而且，它只是那些被民主化的东西太老了，似乎没有这种赢家通吃的现象，如果你想出更好的东西，根本没有办法获得任何牵引力。等等，你刚才声称电子邮件流行是因为你可以从 Unix 做这件事？
Well, one of the reasons. I think email is popular because you can do it totally wrong and it still works. You can just mess it up and just send, you can spam everybody, you can have malformed headers and whatever, and it will basically kind of work and so you can misconfigure your server you don't have to do it right and it somehow still works yeah i guess i guess you know email is popular for a lot of reasons but especially in the work environment where it's it's not hard to move everyone to something else um the email sticks around because we have so many servers at work that are
嗯，原因之一。我认为电子邮件流行是因为你可以完全错误地使用它，它仍然有效。你可以把它搞得一团糟，然后发送，你可以向所有人发送垃圾邮件，你可以有格式错误的标题等等，它基本上还是会以某种方式工作。所以你可以错误配置你的服务器，你不必做得正确，它仍然能以某种方式工作。是的，我想电子邮件流行的原因有很多，特别是在工作环境中，将每个人转移到其他东西并不容易。电子邮件之所以存在，是因为我们在工作中有很多服务器
sending emails by just piping things to send mail yeah and there's like definite trade-offs too like even if there is a better interface or better like usability if it doesn't interoperate with email or if it is like your data is walled up somewhere you can't get to then it comes with real trade-offs so what's the difference between hyper dev and like js fiddle for example so for people don't know js fiddle is this website um you can go there you can write some html and some client-side javascript let's say you want to um Let's say you want someone to teach you how to rotate an image on the browser. Someone has a fiddle for that.
通过管道传输东西到 send mail 来发送电子邮件。是的，而且也有明确的权衡。即使有更好的界面或更好的可用性，如果它不能与电子邮件互操作，或者如果你的数据被锁在某个地方，你无法获取，那么它就会带来真正的权衡。那么 HyperDev 和 JSFiddle 之间有什么区别呢？对于不知道的人，JSFiddle 是这个网站，你可以去那里，你可以编写一些 HTML 和一些客户端 JavaScript。假设你想让某人教你如何在浏览器上旋转图像。有人有一个 fiddle 可以做到这一点。
They send you a link, and you can just see this image rotating and see the source code that generated it. Yeah, so JSFiddle is great. It's a purely client-side tool, though. I guess they publish the HTMLtml and javascript so you can get it back later but its capability is only running in the browser so it's basically a aside from serving up their code snippets it's basically serverless the user's browser does all
他们给你发一个链接，你就可以看到这个图像在旋转，并看到生成它的源代码。是的，所以 JSFiddle 很棒。不过，它是一个纯粹的客户端工具。我想他们发布了 HTML 和 JavaScript，所以你以后可以拿回来，但它的能力仅限于在浏览器中运行。所以除了提供他们的代码片段外，它基本上是无服务器的，用户的浏览器完成了所有
the work to execute the commands uh in hyperDev, you actually get your own server and your own URL that you can post data to. You can get data from other APIs and get it into your application. And so HyperDev gives you a full stack application. You can have the front-end components, the back-end components, and you have your own web server that sits and runs for a little bit.
工作来执行命令。在 HyperDev 中，你实际上拥有自己的服务器和自己的 URL，你可以向其发布数据。你可以从其他 API 获取数据并将其放入你的应用程序中。所以 HyperDev 为你提供了一个全栈应用程序。你可以拥有前端组件、后端组件，并且你拥有自己的 Web 服务器，它会运行一段时间。
So if I... What's HyperDev used for the database? I guess you use Dynamo or one of these things? Yeah, so right now you can use whatever database you want, but we don't really provide something out of the box. We're thinking of adding maybe SQLite just in the file system later,
那么如果我... HyperDev 使用什么数据库？我想你使用 Dynamo 或类似的东西？是的，所以现在你可以使用任何你想要的数据库，但我们并没有真正提供开箱即用的东西。我们正在考虑以后在文件系统中添加 SQLite，
or possibly maybe some Postgres, but what I've done is I've spun up a Heroku-free database and then just use its database URL as an environment variable so HyperDev can talk to it. But you can find any provider like Mongo or Heroku
或者可能是 Postgres，但我所做的是我启动了一个 Heroku 免费数据库，然后将其数据库 URL 作为环境变量使用，这样 HyperDev 就可以与它通信。但你可以找到任何提供商，比如 Mongo 或 Heroku
or any of these little databases or service providers and just plug that straight into your HyperDev app. So if I make a HyperDev app and I start getting 10,000 or let's say 100,000 QPS on my app, what happens? Like, do you, does your electricity bill go up? Do you shut the site down? I mean, what happens when something, when a hyperdive site gets really popular? Yeah. So the specific app that it is will probably slow down a bit. It won't be able to serve all of the requests,
或任何这些小型数据库或服务提供商，并将其直接插入到你的 HyperDev 应用程序中。所以如果我制作了一个 HyperDev 应用程序，并且我的应用程序开始获得 10,000 或 100,000 QPS，会发生什么？比如，你的电费会增加吗？你会关闭网站吗？我的意思是，当一个 HyperDev 网站变得非常流行时会发生什么？是的。它所处的特定应用程序可能会变慢一点。它将无法处理所有的请求，
but it shouldn't impact the other apps too much because each container has a limited amount of resource allocation. So it'll basically be your app won't be able to serve as much, but all the other ones will only be
但它不应该对其他应用程序产生太大影响，因为每个容器都有有限的资源分配。所以基本上你的应用程序将无法提供那么多服务，但所有其他应用程序只会
slightly hindered. And it might add stress on our like proxy server as well but uh well I mean what if the person like what if the person came to you and said hey my hyper dev site is all of a sudden is amazing you know what do I do I mean like they don't want their app to be slow like do you would you work with them to I mean what sort of the next step there, right? Yeah, so since we're starting with basic Node.js and Express apps, there are a lot of ways to speed things up, like using CDN if you're serving images
受到轻微影响。它也可能会给我们的代理服务器带来压力，但嗯，我的意思是，如果那个人来到你面前说，嘿，我的 HyperDev 网站突然变得很棒，你知道我该怎么办？我的意思是，他们不希望他们的应用程序变慢，你会和他们一起工作吗？我的意思是，下一步是什么？是的，因为我们从基本的 Node.js 和 Express 应用程序开始，有很多方法可以加快速度，比如如果你正在提供图像，使用 CDN
instead of serving it through Express from the file system. Maybe making sure the database is probably located in the same aws region if you have another database provider we can try and figure out ways to make sure your stuff is close together and also we're still in beta right now but we want to add paid plans soon so you can upgrade the amount of resources your app has. And I think that should be good for a lot of people because our free tier is, I guess, pretty narrow in what sort of resources you can do.
而不是通过 Express 从文件系统中提供。也许确保数据库位于同一个 AWS 区域，如果你有另一个数据库提供商，我们可以尝试找出方法确保你的东西靠在一起。而且我们现在还处于测试阶段，但我们想很快添加付费计划，这样你就可以升级你的应用程序拥有的资源量。我认为这对很多人来说应该很好，因为我们的免费层在你可以使用的资源方面相当有限。
It's probably great if you have dozens or hundreds or maybe thousands of requests. But if you have tens of thousands or something with extremely high traffic, it will definitely not be enough. So we would like to add ways where you can just upgrade your app without having to worry about it too much. Just pay more money and your problems go away. Oh, man, that sounds awesome.
如果你有几十个、几百个或几千个请求，这可能很棒。但如果你有数万个请求或流量极高，这绝对是不够的。所以我们想添加一些方法，让你只需升级你的应用程序，而不必太担心它。只需支付更多的钱，你的问题就会消失。哦，天哪，那听起来太棒了。
Yeah. Yeah, that could apply to so many things. Our plan is that HyperDev is really easy to get started and great for prototyping. And our secret trick is once your app works and then your boss sees it, he'll say, great, ship it to production. You try and tell him, no, it's just a prototype,
是的。是的，这可以应用于很多事情。我们的计划是 HyperDev 非常容易上手，非常适合原型设计。我们的秘密技巧是，一旦你的应用程序工作了，然后你的老板看到了，他会说，太棒了，发布到生产环境。你试图告诉他，不，这只是一个原型，
but he won't listen, and then it gets popular. He's like, well, we could just pay him money and it'll still work. So that's our plan. That's awesome. Yeah, we could just pay them money and it'll still work. That's our plan. That's awesome. Yeah, I mean, that plan worked very well for GitHub and Dropbox and a lot of other companies.
但他不会听，然后它就流行起来了。他会说，好吧，我们可以付钱给他们，它仍然会工作。所以这就是我们的计划。那太棒了。是的，我们可以付钱给他们，它仍然会工作。这是我们的计划。那太棒了。是的，我的意思是，那个计划对 GitHub、Dropbox 和许多其他公司来说非常有效。
So I think you're in good company. No pun intended. Yeah, we're stealing from the best. Yeah, that's right. Steal from the forgotten masters. Cool. Yeah, that's awesome. I tried it, actually.
所以我认为你处于很好的公司。没有双关语的意思。是的，我们在向最好的学习。是的，没错。从被遗忘的大师那里偷师。酷。是的，那太棒了。我实际上试过了。
I made a website, added some of the Node.js code, added some dependencies. It works really, really well, well, he's my kid's older now, too. But he used to like, you know, just vomit on me and I have to clean his poop and stuff like that. But before that, I used to be kind of like a perfectionist, like everything had to be kind of perfect. And especially with computers, if you know, there was when I first started getting into Linux, I wouldn't I was installing Mandrake, which doesn't even exist anymore. I think they forked it and it's Mandrake now. But I was installing mandrake which doesn't even exist anymore i think they forked it and it's mandriva now but i was installing mandrake linux and if i if i got into like the
我制作了一个网站，添加了一些 Node.js 代码，添加了一些依赖项。它工作得非常好，嗯，他现在也是我孩子的大了。但他过去喜欢，你知道，只是在我身上呕吐，我必须清理他的大便之类的东西。但在那之前，我曾经是一个完美主义者，一切都必须是完美的。特别是在计算机方面，如果，你知道，当我第一次开始接触 Linux 时，我安装了 Mandrake，它现在甚至不存在了。我想他们分叉了它，现在是 Mandriva。但我当时正在安装 Mandrake Linux，如果我遇到了
smallest snag i reinstalled the os so i mean i was just reinstalling the os every day and uh um and i because it's it's part of it is you feel like you have no control and so you know you starting from scratch is the only thing that you can do. And so it's much harder to sort of get yourself out of a ditch. And it's also kind of like more educational, just keep starting from scratch and trying different avenues and things like that. It's like a choose-your-own-adventure book. And HyperDev allows you to do that with web programming. If you're just starting out, you make a website and you start dabbling.
最小的障碍，我就重新安装操作系统。所以我的意思是，我每天都在重新安装操作系统，而且因为部分原因是你会觉得你没有控制权，所以你知道，从头开始是你唯一能做的事情。所以很难让自己摆脱困境。而且这也有点像更具教育意义，只是不断从头开始并尝试不同的途径等等。这就像一本“选择你自己的冒险”书。而 HyperDev 允许你用 Web 编程做到这一点。如果你刚开始，你制作一个网站并开始涉足。
You end up kind of in a bad spot and you don't really know what's going on. You haven't spent too much time. You can just blow it away and start over. You never have to worry about blowing up your computer or anything like that because you're not the one serving. You're going to blow up Daniel's computer. Yeah, and we know how to deal with that. Yeah, that's right.
你最终处于一个糟糕的境地，你真的不知道发生了什么。你没有花太多时间。你可以直接把它吹走并重新开始。你永远不必担心炸毁你的电脑之类的东西，因为你不是那个提供服务的人。你要炸毁的是 Daniel 的电脑。是的，我们知道如何处理这个问题。是的，没错。
So definitely check it out if you're starting out. Even if you're not, I found it akin to JSFiddle, but with all the server-side capability, which is really cool. And yeah, thanks for coming on the show. Super interesting. And yeah, definitely everyone tried out. It only takes a minute. Cool.
所以如果你刚开始，一定要看看它。即使你不是，我也发现它类似于 JSFiddle，但具有所有的服务器端功能，这真的很酷。是的，谢谢你来到节目。超级有趣。是的，每个人一定要试一试。只需要一分钟。酷。
Thanks, guys. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution ShareAlike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。